you've heard the rumors you've read the  reports and now you can get your first  look at destiny 2 i'm tony and this is  your teasing gamespot news update  destiny tues first official teaser  titled last call has been released it  looks good it has some humor and it sets  the stage for the real destiny 2 trailer  that drops Thursday March 30th at ten  a.m. Pacific 1 p.m. eastern and this all  comes hot on the heels of the  announcement of the game's title simply  being destiny to destiny to was slated  to release this year and sometimes ps4  exclusive content has also been  confirmed be sure to subscribe to  gamespot to be the first to know all the  details and for some spacefaring action  right now why not check out the latest  episode of reboot all about Mass Effect  Andromeda  [Music]  you